[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi di voi riconosce questa immagine del
migliaia di persone con la testa rivolta
verso l'alto che stanno aspettando che
cosa piazza san pietro
l'elezione di papa quindi tutti lì
pronti si vede qualche sporadico
telefonino qui e là che si affaccia da
qualche parte stessa immagine 2013 c'è
una piccola differenza sembra sembra di
sì cioè qualche telefono qualche e
tablet
qualche fotocamera fotocamera in più
augurando lunga vita questo papa sarei
curioso di vedere cosa succederà la
prossima volta che ci sarà la stessa
identica scena otto anni otto anni che
sono stati un'era geologica dal punto di
vista tecnologico in cui veramente la
tecnologia entrata nella vita di ognuno
di noi maniera estremamente pervasiva
chi di voi almeno tre device un telefono
un pc fisso un pc portatile incredibile
chi ne ha quattro quindi a meno anche
uno smartwatch un altro tablet a caso
secondo chi ne ha cinque quindi non fa i
test 6 fotografo ne avrai anche molti
molti di più
pensate che da qui al 2020 7.6 miliardi
di persone nel mondo
ci saranno 50 miliardi di device
interconnessi che scambiano
costantemente dati e che quindi
veramente fanno si chiede viviamo come
in simbiosi con questi device spesso
addirittura mi verrebbe da dire quasi in
modo inconsapevole mettiamo a
disposizione tutti questi dati
attraverso tutti questi dispositivi
interconnessi la stessa cosa è successo
nel mondo del lavoro
dalla prima rivoluzione industriale del
1780 con la macchina e vapore a quella
dell'elettricità e del petrolio del 1870
che quindi ha permesso di iniziare la
produzione di massa per poi arrivare al
1970 quando la robotica ed informatica è
entrata nel mondo del lavoro e quindi
aumentando ancora di più la produttività
arriviamo al giorno d'oggi in cui si
parla così tanto di questa quarta
rivoluzione industriale che è quella in
cui le macchine parlano con le macchine
le macchine parlano con gli uomini
i di prodotti con contengono una
quantità di dati infiniti per cui si è
creato una vera e propria connessione
fra tutte le fasi della filiera
produttiva dai fornitori fino al cliente
finale quelli con un ente al connessione
profonda e con la possibilità di
personalizzare sempre di più i prodotti
bene ma tutta questa tecnologia tutti
questi investimenti in robotica in
manifattura additiva in aiuti in
artificial intelligence hanno prodotto
un reale vantaggio per le aziende
italiane come imprenditore come manager
come professionisti so che ce ne sono
tanti qui in sala
che cosa manca per far sì che veramente
tutta questa tecnologia sia efficace
nelle nostre aziende
perché se ci pensate ai vertici sarà la
crisi internazionale ma siamo ancora un
livello in cui il costo del lavoro per
unita prodotto in italia del 30 per
cento superiore rispetto alla germania
nonostante sia italia che giovani
avevano fatto tantissimi investimenti in
tecnologia e industria 4.0 in questi
anni spesso quello che succede è che
quello che viviamo fuori dal lavoro
quindi questa profonde interconnessione
con tutti questi nostri device
interconnessi quando entriamo al lavoro
diventiamo purtroppo degli analfabeti
digitali il vero sforzo che noi possiamo
fare per la nazione come imprenditori
come professionisti come manager e
capire veramente in che modo possiamo
dare alle nostre persone la cultura
digitale che facessi veramente che la
tecnologia di venti di valore di valore
aggiunto pensate ormai penso che nel
momento in cui scrivevamo con la carta
ci mandavamo i documenti e poi li di
tavano con il pennarello giallo e la
penna blu la pena cosa sia passato però
pensate ancora oggi quante volte
scriviamo dei documenti dal nostro pc
fisso li mandiamo via e mail l'icontro
mandiamo via email dopo averli editati
perché ogni tanto che ci siamo dei
documenti si chiamano tipo budget dei
budget dei budget david after questo non
cambiarono più e poi li archiviamo
puntualmente dove sul nostro pc perché
il nostro documento e guai a chi lo
tocca e quindi non è più accessibile
agli altri bene tutto questo la
tecnologia e ovviamente perfettamente di
superarlo oggi con il cloud noi possiamo
accedere con i nostri device ovunque in
modo semplice collaborare sullo stesso
documento e metterli a disposizione di
tutte le persone che devono avere
accesso a quel documento in modo
veramente che ci sia la collaborazione e
la comunicazione e la condivisione delle
informazioni essenziali per il nostro
lavoro
ecco è questo che le nostre aziende
devono fare come dice una ricerca
recente del politecnico di milano per
far sì che la cultura di che la
tecnologia veramente abbia un valore
aggiunto nelle nostre aziende di a quel
vantaggio che tutti vogliamo per
rimanere competitivi dobbiamo prima di
tutto lavorare sulla cultura digitale
delle nostre persone e quindi li
organizzare lavoro inventandoci anche di
modelli di leadership quindi di gestione
delle persone diverse e inserendo in
azienda i ruoli che ancora che ancora
mancano
allora è questa la sfida che veramente
dopo a ognuno di voi in primis a me
stesso come imprenditore come manager
capire in che modo possiamo portare
questa cultura digitale in azienda in
modo che insieme alla tecnologia
digitale veramente ci sia il business
digitale perché la rivoluzione digitale
prima di tutto una rivoluzione culturale
che cosa succede quando si riesce ad
andare in questa direzione
succede che le persone valorizzano il
proprio talento
quindi le persone in azienda sono capaci
di esprimere il meglio perché non sono
solo i millenials digitalizzati quelli
che possono far fare questo salto di
qualità delle nostre aziende sono anche
le persone di 30 40 50 60 anni che se
entrano nella cultura digitale possono
trasformare il business delle nostre
aziende e quindi inventarsi dei nuovi
paradigmi un po come se ci fossimo che
nel 68 il salto in alto il salto foscoli
tutti andavano sempre verso la sta in
maniera frontale facendo salto ventrale
e lui si inventa qualcosa di
completamente nuovo preso una
traiettoria laterale improvvisamente si
voltò verso la st è la traversa saltando
la verso l'indietro cambio di paradigma
pensiero 10 per cambiare completamente
quello a cui siamo abituati per creare
qualcosa che ancora non esiste gli
esempi noti sono tanti da tesla che ha
inventato un nuovo la nuova auto
elettrica la whatsapp che ha
rivoluzionato il nostro modo di
comunicare a hoover che è cambiato il
modo di cambiare di vivere la città e di
muoversi in città netflix che ha
cambiato il modo di
gli eredi di guardare la televisione ma
questi sono esempi mondiali da cosa che
ci deve interessare qui in italia
bergamo e dire è possibile applicare
cultura digitale tecnologia digitale
anche nelle nostre aziende
la risposta è sì mi e ci sono tanti
champion tante aziende vincenti che lo
stanno facendo anche del territorio come
jacko che un'azienda che fa
impiantistica automotive e che ha messo
la tecnologia sui propri impianti per
migliorare la manutenzione e dare più
informazione all'utente della macchina
quindi migliorare l'esperienza di
utilizzo dell'auto noberasco chi non ha
mai mangiato un frutta secca noberasco
che da azienda che vendeva mezzo
pacchetti da mezzo chilo è diventata una
lifestyle company che vende pacchetti
mono sacchetti monodose in tutti i punti
vendita lago che non fa più mobili ma fa
con walking interconnessi in cui i
mobili di ago
dialogano con le persone ai mete che
un'azienda qui del territorio che non fa
più semplicemente coperte per scaldare
il nostro sonno ma diventata un'azienda
che grazie alla tecnologia messa sui
propri prodotti migliora la qualità del
sonno e quindi la qualità della vita di
ognuno di noi
allora questa è la vera rivoluzione
digitale è il modo in cui la cultura
digitale insieme la tecnologia digitale
crea quelle aziende che poi rimangono
competitive nel mondo le nostre
multinazionali tascabili che possono
veramente permetterci di mantenere la
competitività del nostro paese
nel lungo periodo e tutto questo
discorso ovviamente poi ha una
ripercussione profonda anche sulla vita
di ognuno di noi
io ho avuto la fortuna in questi ultimo
anno di sperimentare quello che sta
succedendo in un campo
sì è vero molto sensibile e molto
delicato eticamente complesso come
quello della medicina
in lombardia si sta facendo medicina
predittiva sulle patologie croniche
patologie croniche sono quelle patologie
dall'ipertensione al diabete andando
fino alla patologia purtroppo molto più
gravi nelle quali il paziente deve
essere curato per un lungo periodo di
tempo
bene grazie a 18 anni di visite
specialistiche che sono stati presi e
archiviate grazie a 11 anni di
prescrizioni farmaceutiche
grazie a 160 milioni di visite
specialistiche fatte ogni anno s'è
creato un grandissimo database che ha
permesso di storicizzare segmentari
malati cronici e individuare in
particolare quei 3 milioni fra quei 3
milioni e 200mila pazienti cronici
pensate 3 milioni e 200 mila su un
totale di 10 milioni di abitanti in
lombardia individuale in particolare
quel 40 per cento di fragili che sono
over 70 e minori che non sanno nemmeno
di essere codici e che quindi spesso
accedono al servizio sanitario nazionale
andando a fare più visite specialistiche
in più ospedali spendendo un sacco di
soldi e avendo un servizio che spesso
non è efficace bene queste persone hanno
ricevuto due anni fa e l'anno scorso una
lettera a casa in cui gli viene detto
guarda vai da quel gestore vai da quel
clinical manager vai libera avevo un
punto di accesso unico al sistema
sanitario quello ti prenderai si
prendeva cura di te quindi non sarai tu
a doverti curarla ci sarà il sistema
sanitario che si prende cura di te
ottimizzerà tutto il tuo percorso
sanitario facendo in modo che la
topologia venga curata nel migliore dei
modi
e ovviamente diminuendo anche il costo
per il servizio sanitario
allora questo anche nella pubblica
amministrazione è il futuro grazie alla
tecnologia
il dato che permette di entrare in un
campo sensibile come quello della
medicina ottimizzando la vita di ognuno
di noi e si andrà ulteriormente avanti
perché ancora una volta queste basi dati
saranno costantemente arricchite grazie
agli smartphone agli smartphone e ai
misuratori di glucosio o agli indumenti
che abbiamo sensorizzati in cui quindi
possono continuamente trasmettere dati
ad esempio i malati di diabete
arricchiranno sempre di più la base dati
sulla quale sarà possibile imparare e
segmentare ancora meglio e quindi cura
va ancora meglio le singole patologie
facendo in modo che quindi la medicina
sia sempre più personalizzata per la
singola persona grazie al piano di
assistenza individuale di cui vi parlavo
poc'anzi è che a volte tutto questo apre
anche dei temi di etica di deontologia
di privacy ma mettiamoci dall'altro
punto di vista siamo per la prima volta
di fronte all'occasione in cui passiamo
da descrivere che cosa è successo al
perché è successo non solo ad anticipare
ma addirittura poter dare la migliore
azione clinica successiva per far sì che
una patologia cronica non insorga nel
paziente o per touran appena insorge
quindi avere un livello di cura
personalizzato
che quindi fa in modo che ogni singolo
paziente sia soddisfatto e abbia la
migliore cura la migliore cura possibile
tutto questo è qui oggi e come
imprenditore come me veramente spero che
ognuno di noi possa dare un contributo a
far sì che veramente la tecnologia entri
in questo modo anche facendoci carico di
quello che è il sistema pubblico
offrendo il nostro tempo parte del
nostro tempo perché è solo se noi che
portiamo avanti la cultura digitale
mettiamo un po del nostro tempo a
disposizione anche del del settore
pubblico che è possibile ottenere questi
risultati
e come diceva il titolo della del mio
speech penso che questo sia un bel
esempio in cui il paziente al centro
grazie una revisione del ruolo del
personale sanitario grazie alla
tecnologia grazie ai dati si ottiene
veramente una personalizzazione la
migliore cura e quindi l'innovazione e
la tecnologia sono davvero al servizio
della persona
grazie
[Applauso]